another day of clashes in the streets of
Venezuela after opposition leader Juan Y
Joe called for an uprising against the
socialist Maduro regime you've probably
noticed that the protesters there are
unarmed and can't really fight back
against the government
that's because Venezuela banned private
gun ownership in 2012 while covering the
chaos yesterday the mainstream media
accidentally slipped up and defended
America's Second Amendment watch you
have to understand in Venezuela gun
ownership is not something that is open
to everybody so if the military have the
guns they have the power and as long as
Nicolas Maduro controls the military he
controls the country Jesse so quite a
slip-up there and I always wonder why
it's so hard for people in media to
realize that what's happening over there
could happen over here same thing for
socialism right it's like oh that's over
there that that's happening over there
but that is what the fear is that
ultimately one day could that happen
here if all of our rights are taken away
the media never looks to reality for
examples they can see everything
happening all over the world but then
when you say okay well what about its
impact here in the United States they
never take that to heart I think it was
a Acosta Jim for CNN who accidentally
made the case for the wall when he went
down to once in a while these things
happens both but this isn't theoretical
Eric's wall well who's running for
president has talked about gun
confiscation Stacey Abrams Georgia
Democrat has also talked about gun
confiscation and actually going
door-to-door to enforce the confiscation
so when conservatives in this country
talk about the Second Amendment and
rights that need to be protected it's
not theoretical we've seen the last
administration use the IRS to target the
Tea Party we've seen the last
administration violate allegedly the
privacy of Trump campaign officials
we've seen a lot of the the government
abused their power and when you look at
examples of Venezuela that is that is
quintessential government abuse of power
and not a peaceful transfer of power
which we actually didn't really have
last time as well and do you think that
if those people had guns there'd be
anything but more cash
more violence and more than prevent
being egregious let me ask you my ranch
fob I just in New York City you think
that if you had a gun you could even
stand up to the New York City Police
Department much less the state National
Guard or the US military I think if all
the American people are armed you don't
think that that citizenry has a right to
they are faced with a tyrannical leader
right yes they're protesting but they're
powerless because they're not still
really they're being run over by
military tanks streets because the
military is mostly exciting with Maduro
and the rest of the population that are
fighting for their rights they're
unarmed first of all there's no apples
in Orange comparison between the US and
another country but there is no reality
the idea that if some people had had and
guns even you know automatic weapons
they could stand up to the military no
that's an invitation to more death than
cast it's a reach by people who are
trying to make the argument for guns for
everyone in the USA correct
you know the anti Second Amendment
activists often use this or dismiss the
argument that lawful gun ownership
prevents is there an organic defense
against tyranny that you know as long as
we have the Second Amendment we have
guns there's probably never gonna be an
opportunity for a government to to turn
to radical or socialist or fascist in
the United States some would argue Trump
is already there but I got you the media
accidentally makes the case for
everything they are against and Trump is
a great example because I think they
elected Trump by making the case against
him but so here's a neat question why is
it only socialist countries who want to
take away your guns because they know
ultimately that their ideology can only
be coerced right so guns make that
coercion impossible once the guns are in
the hands of the population you can no
longer control the population yeah Jane
it's funny because I was gonna make the
same argument but the the reverse which
is the best way to prevent this from
ever happening here is it continue to
have a free and fair country that
respects the rule of law yeah absolutely
and also it's important to note that
when the net web ins confiscation plan
was put into place only 37 firearms were
turned over voluntarily
did not want to do that themselves they
were forced and that's when the
confiscation came into play